bei einer messerattacke in der nähe der
früheren redaktion der satirezeitschrift
charlie hebdo in paris sind am freitag
nach angaben des französischen
ministerpräsidenten jokers 64 menschen
verletzt worden
zwei der opfer erlitten nach angaben aus
polizeikreisen lebensgefährliche wunden
ein verdächtiger sei festgenommen worden
hieß es
das gebiet um das gebäude ist nach dem
fund eines verdächtigen päckchens
abgeriegelt worden
am tatort haben die ermittler ein großes
messer entdeckt bei einem anschlag auf
die redaktion von charlie otto waren im
januar 2015 zwölf menschen getötet
worden
vor drei wochen begann der prozess gegen
14 angeklagte die kontakte in die
islamistische szene haben sollen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren